OF LYING, POMPOSITY,
SMUGNESS, AND GROUP THINK.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
BUCKLE UP.
TONIGHT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS OFFICIALLY A DUMPSTER
FIRE FAR LEFT RADICALISM
SPINNING IN A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
CLAMORING FOR IMPEACHMENT
FANTASIES.
MORE SUBPOENA STUNTS AND, OF
COURSE, FAR LEFT SOCIALISM
THE LIKES OF WHICH WOULD
DESTROY THIS COUNTRY.
WELL NOW TONIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT, I IS STANDING
STRONG AGAINST THIS
NEVER-ENDING HARASSMENT AND
HE NOW HAS VOWED TO FIGHT
EVERY SINGLE STEP OF THE WAY
RIGHT THING TO DO.
WE HAVE FULL COVERAGE.
OPERATION CROSS HIRE
HURRICANE NOW OFFICIALLY
MORPHED INTO CROSSFIRE
BOOMERANG FOR THE CLINTONS,
THE DEMOCRATS AND ALL DEEP
STATE ACTORS THAT ABUSED
POWER.
SPOTLIGHT SHINES BRIGHTER ON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES ALONG WITH MAJOR NEW
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT
SURROUNDING NOTORIOUS EMAIL
SERVER YES INVOLVING BARACK
OBAMA AND ANTHONY WEINER.
WE WILL GIVE YOU ALL THE
DETAILS.
WE START WITH AN EVEN BIGGER
DEVELOPMENT OF THE TIN FOIL
HAT CONSPIRACY MEDIA MOB
WHAT THEY HAVEN'T TELLING
YOU ABOUT BECAUSE WE ARE
LEARNING FROM "THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER" TONIGHT
ROBERT MUELLER'S REPORT
CONTAINS A CLAIM THAT
RUSSIANS RECORDED THEN
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
HAVING PHONE SEX WITH MONICA
LEWENSKI BACK IN THE 1990S.
WOW.
THE EXPLOSION ALLEGEDLY
REPORTEDLY IS IN THE
REDACTED REPORT RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC, NOT THERE BUT
IT'S IN THE REDACTED
SECTION.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES TALKING
TO EXAMINER, THE REDACTION
COMES ON PAGE 109 OF
MUELLER'S REPORT AND
REFERENCES A MEETING BETWEEN
JARED KUSHNER AND A RUSSIAN
PUBLISHER WHERE HE DETAILED
THIS CLAIM.
REMEMBER, KEN STARR IN HIS
1998 REPORT IDENTIFIED AT
LEAST 17 PHONE SEX CALLS
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN 1996
AND '97.
AND WROTE THAT PRESIDENT
CLINTON, QUOTE:  SUSPECTED
THAT FOREIGN EMBASSY WAS
TAPPING HIS TELEPHONE.
BUT HE DID IT ANYWAY.
EVEN PROPOSING, QUOTE, COVER
STORIES TO LEWENSKI IF IT
TURNED OUT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY BEING MONITORED.
SO FAR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THEY ARE REFUSING TO COMMENT
BUT WOULDN'T IT BE SOMETHING
HEAR THE BOOMERANG?
OPERATION BOOMERANG NOT
HURRICANE AFTER ALL THE
MEDIA HYSTERIA SURROUNDING
TRUMP AND RUSSIA AND STORMY,
STORMY, STORMY, THE LIES,
THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THE
PHONY DOSSIER URANIUM ONE
THAT IT WAS THE CLINTONS
TOTALLY COMPROMISED ALL
ALONG AND EVERYTHING THEY
WERE ACCUSING TRUMP OF WAS
ACTUALLY TRUE ABOUT THEM.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WERE THE ONES
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
YES, THEY PAID FOR A DIRTY
STEELE DOSSIER.
YEAH WITH RUSSIAN LIES.
HILLARY, SHE WAS THE ONE
THAT USED THE PRIVATE SECRET
SERVER THAT PUT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AT RISK.
WE BELIEVE SIX FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
HACKETTED INTO THAT AND EVEN
NOW THE STORY IS TAKING A
BIGGER TURN.
ACCORDING TO JUDICIAL WATCH,
FORMER SENIOR FBI OFFICIAL
BILL PRESTEP ADMITTED UNDER
OATH IN COURT ORDERED
DISCOVERY THAT THE AGENCY
FOUND CLINTON EMAIL RECORDS
FROM HER PRIVATE SERVER IN
THE USAMA BIN LADEN WHITE
HOUSE.
SPECIFICALLY THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
OF PRESIDENT OBAMA.
NOW, AGAIN, HE ASKED WHAT
DID OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN DID
HE KNOW IT?
WE'RE THE FIRST TO ASK AND
WE DO NEED AN ANSWER.
THE STORY DOESN'T STOP THERE
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE
CONFIRMATION TONIGHT THAT
NEARLY 49 NOW, CLINTON
EMAILS WERE FOUND ON ANTHONY
WEINER'S LAPTOP.
AND WHO WANTS TO GUESS?
THEY ALL WEREN'T ABOUT GRAND
KIDS.
YOGA, A WEDDING AND A
FUNERAL AS SHE CLAIMED WHAT
DOGS
DOES THIS ALL MEAN BARACK
OBAMA NOW APPEARS TO BE MORE
FIRMLY IMINDICATED IN THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
SCHEME.
ONE HIGH RANKING OFFICIAL.
WE KNOW OBAMA EMAILED
HILLARY ON HER PRIVATE
SERVER.
THE GREAT IRONY IN ALL OF
THIS IS THAT HILLARY STILL
THINKS SHE DID NOTHING WRONG
IS SHE SURE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, OH, YEAH, SHE IS
CERTAIN HE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE.
CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ANY OTHER PERSON WHO HAS
ENGAGED IN THOSE ACTS WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN INDICTED
BUT BECAUSE OF THE RULE IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT
YOU CAN'T INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT, AS I READ IT,
BASICALLY WHAT I THOUGHT IT
WAS SAYING IS LOOK, WE THINK
HE OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
HERE ARE 11 EXAMPLES OF WHY
WE THINK HE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE BUT WE'RE UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THEIR RULE IS
YOU CAN'T INDICT.
>> Sean: WELL, NOW, CLINTON
DOUBLED DOWN IN HER DELUSION
IN AN OP-ED PUBLISHED TODAY
IN THE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WRITING QUOTE:  CONGRESS
CAN'T FORGET THAT THE ISSUE
TODAY IS NOT JUST POSSIBLE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IT'S IT'S
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS PROVED HIMSELF
UNWILLING TO DEFEND OUR
NATION FROM A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER.
HOW COULD ANY ONE INDIVIDUAL
BE THIS OUT OF TOUCH OR THIS
DISCONNECTED FROM REALITY?
NOW, FIRST OFF, HILLARY, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MADE THE
DETERMINATION ALONG WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL ROD
ROSENSTEIN, WITHOUT EVEN
CONSIDERING AS YOU SAID
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT.
THAT DETERMINATION WAS MADE
WITHOUT THAT THAT THE
EVIDENCE DID NOT CHARGE ANY
OBSTRUCTION.
NOT ANY UNDERLYING CRIME
LIKE YOUR CASE.
THIS DIRECTLY FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL QUOTE OUR
DETERMINATION WAS MADE
WITHOUT REGARD TO AND IS NOT
BASED ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS THAT
SURROUNDED INDICTMENT AND
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OF A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ANY OTHER PERSON, LET'S TALK
ABOUT YOUR OBSTRUCTION,
HILLARY.
YOUR VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
YOUR PUTTING AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK.
REMEMBER, WE HAVE
OVERWHELMING
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE OF
YOUR MISHANDLING OF TOP
SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON A PRIVATE
SERVER, EVEN COMEY ADMITTED
YOU HAD IT.
REMEMBER TOP FBI LAWYER JIM
BAKER THOUGHT YOU SHOULD BE
INDICTED.
INCONVO TRERTABLE EVIDENCE
OF OBSTRUCTION.
WHY DID YOU DESTROY 33,000
EMAILS AND BLEACH BIT THE
HARD DRIVE AND DESTROY THE
SMARTED PHONES WITH HAMMERS
AND REMOVE THE SIM CARDS?
THAT MEANS INTENT.
THE INTENT WAS TO GET RID OF
THE EVIDENCE.
BECAUSE OF THE UNDERLYING
CRIME THE ESPIONAGE ACT 18
USC 793.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA IGNORES
ALL OF, THIS THE CORRUPTION,
THE -- DON'T FORGET ABOUT
ALL THE OTHER CLINTON
RUSSIA.
REMEMBER BILL HOW ARE YOU
DOING ON MOSCOW SPEECHES
DURING THE URANIUM ONE DEAL
TWICE HIS FEE?
HILLARY SIGNED OFF ON THAT
DEAL IN THE KICK BACKS FROM
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THAT
DEAL, $145 MILLION EVEN
WHILE IT WAS KNOWN PUTIN HAD
THUGS IN AMERICA.
HE HAD A SPY IN HIS RING IN
AMERICA.
REMEMBER, WE INTERVIEWED
WILLIAM CAMPBELL, BRIBERY,
EXTORTION, MONEY LAUNDRY,
KICK BACKS, TRYING TO GET A
FOOT HOLD IN OUR URANIUM
MARKET.
WILLIAM CAMPBELL WAS ON THIS
SHOW, HE EXPOSED IT THAT'S
REAL COLLUSION.
AND THAT'S REAL OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE WHICH WE HAVE
MORE OF IN A MINUTE.
AS WE TURN TO OUR HANNITY
MEDIA WATCH REALITY CHECK.
NOW, WITH NO CREDIBILITY
LEFT TO LOSE, WELL, THE
MEDIA, MOB, THEIR LIES,
EXPOSED AND THE AVALANCHE OF
TRUTH CASCADING DOWN IN THE
DAYS, WEEKS AND MONTHS
AHEAD.
SO WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY ARE ACTUAL PATTING
THEMSELVES ON THE BACK.
GREAT COVERAGE OF TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
THEY WERE WRONG SO OFTEN,
ALMOST EVERY DAY.
AND THEY IGNORED THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, THE BIGGEST
STORY THEY COULD HAVE EVER
HAD IN THEIR LIFE.
BUT WE WERE HERE DOING THEIR
JOB FOR THEM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
WE'LL EVER DO ANYTHING
HARDER THAN THAT.
>> I'M SO PROUD OF OUR
COVERAGE NBC NEWS IS THE
BEST OF THE BEST.
>> THE OTHER THING THIS
REPORT DID IS IT REALLY
CORROBORATED A LOT OF GOOD
JOURNALISM THAT WAS DONE.
>> TIME AND AGAIN IN THIS
MUELLER REPORT, REPORTING
FROM MAJOR NEWS OUTLETS IS
CONFIRMED IN THIS MUELLER
REPORT AS BEING ACCURATE.
>> HOW DID THAT GUY JUST GET
AN AWARD AND A BOOK DEAL
YOU?
CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THEY LOVE THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE NO CAPACITY FOR
INTROSPECTION,
SELF-REFLECTION,
SELF-CRITICISM, A.
ACCOUNTABILITY?
HOW MANY TIMES ON THIS SHOW
HAVE WE EXPOSED OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THEIR
LIES AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
LIST AFTER LIST.
FAKE NUMBER NEWS STORY AFTER
FAKE NEWS STORY ALL THE
ALL-STARS AT THEIR WORSE.
WHERE IS THE MEDIA?
THEY ARE REALLY GOING TO
LOSE THIS WHOLENING IN
AUGUST OF THIS.
SOON WE WILL HAVE MORE
CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY COMING
OUT PROVING WE HAVE BEEN
RIGHT ALL ALONG.
HAVE BEEN WRONG.
WE WILL HAVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR HAS SAID HE HAS
LAUNCHED AN INVESTIGATION
INTO SPYING INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND ALL MATTERS
SURROUNDING THE
INVESTIGATION.
A WITCH-HUNT AGAINST THE
SITTING PRESIDENT.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS FROM
CONGRESSMAN NUNES.
THE HOROWITZ, OH YEAH THE
FISA INVESTIGATION.
GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
HILLARY'S RUSSIAN BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR LIES.
THE 302Ss.
LEAKING INTELLIGENCE.
UNMASKING AMERICANS.
ALSO, LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO
CARTER PAGE, SPIES, STEPHON
HALPER CHECKING IN ON PAIGE
AND PAPADOPOULOS.
HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER.
NEVER VERIFIED AND
CORROBORATED.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" THIS WEEK IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ONE BIG
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
ALSO GET GANG OF 8
INFORMATION.
WHETHER THE MEDIA MOB LIKES
THIS OR NOT, THIS AVALANCHE
IS REAL.
AND TRUTH AND JUSTICE ARE
COMING.
AND ALL WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS
STANDING STRONG AND FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS
THEY CAN'T LET IT GO NOW
EVER THE PRESIDENT WAS THE
MOST COOPERATIVE PRESIDENT
IN HISTORY.
NOT ONCE EVER INVOKING
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE DID HAVE THE RIGHT UNDER
ARTICLE 2 TO FIRE MUELLER.
ROSENSTEIN COULD HAVE DONE
IT.
JUST BECAUSE HE SAID THESE
PEOPLE ARE HORRIBLE NEED TO
BE FIRED HE DIDN'T DO IT.
DID HE?
JUST LIKE THEY TALKED ABOUT
SECRETLY RECORDING THE
PRESIDENT AND INVOKING THE
25TH AMENDMENT.
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT IT,
TALKED ABOUT IT, DIDN'T DO
IT.
NOW, WITH THEIR LATEST OF
COURSE BEING CONGRESS BID TO
BRING IN DON MCGAHN WHY WAS
HE EVER ALLOWED TO TALK FOR
30 HOURS IN THE FIRST PLACE?
I DON'T GET THAT.
THAT WAS AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE MOMENT.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT
EARLIER TODAY.
IS HE FIGHTING BACK.
>> WELL, THE SUBPOENA IS
RIDICULOUS.
WE HAVE BEEN.
I HAVE BEEN THE MOST
TRANSPARENTS PRESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY BY
FAR.
WOULD
WEULD
WE JD
WE JUST WENT THROUGH THE
MUELLER WITCH-HUNT WHERE YOU
HAD REALLY 18 ANGRY
DEMOCRATS THAT HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP THEY HATE
HIM WITH A PASSION.
THEY WERE CONTRIBUTORS IN
MANY CASES HILLARY CLINTON.
HATE HIM WITH A PASSION.
HOW THEY PICKED THIS PANEL I
DON'T KNOW.
AND THEY CAME UP WITH NO
COLLUSION AND THEY ACTUALLY
ALSO CAME UP WITH NO
OBSTRUCTION.
WELL, WE ARE FIGHTING ALL
THE SUBPOENAS.
LOOK, THESE AREN'T LIKE
IMPARTIAL PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
WIN 2020.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WIN
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT I SEE.
STEVE: WE HAVE
>> Sean: MEDIA MOB STOP AT
NOTHING TO MAKE EVERY WAKING
MOMENT A PUBLIC TRIAL
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND
ANYONE WHO LIKES DONALD
TRUMP.
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE LIKE
US.
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, WE
CLING TO GOD, OUR GUNS,
BIBLES, RELIGION.
OKAY, THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
HEART AND SOUL OF THIS
COUNTRY NO CONCERN FOR THE
LAW.
DOCTRINE OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE?
CONSTITUTION?
FACTS?
REALITY?
THEY PUSH COLLUSION,
HYSTERIA FOR THREE YEARS.
FOUR TIMES NOW.
FOUR TIMES NO COLLUSION NO
CONCERN WITH ANY AGENDA TO
MAKE THIS COUNTRY BETTER?
MORE SAFE MORE PROSPEROUS NO
MORE SECURE?
WANT TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
THE PRESIDENT EVERY MINUTE,
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY ON
ANYTHING BECAUSE YOU ARE
CONSUMED WITH YOUR
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE?
YOU HAVE IGNORED, YOU
IDIOTS, THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
AND YOU HAVE IGNORED AN
EFFORT TO TAKE DOWN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT AND
RIGGING AN INVESTIGATION
INTO A POLITICAL CANDIDATE
AND TRYING TO RIG A 2016
ELECTION.
YOU IGNORED THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING THIS COUNTRY.
EVERYTHING FOR THE ECONOMY,
FOREIGN POLICY, DIPLOMACY,
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY AT
OUR BORDERS, FOR CRYING OUT
LOUD.
HANNITY WATCH ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THERE IS A
TOTAL SYSTEM MELTEDDOWN AND
IT'S REAL AND IT'S NOT
MANUFACTURED.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
SURGING.
BORDER PATROL HAD NEAR
RECORD APPREHENSIONS IN
MARCH.
U.S.A. BORDER PERSONNEL THEY
ARE OVERWHELMED.
DRUG TRAFFICKERS, CARTELS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, THEY ARE
EXPLOITING THIS WEAKNESS OF
NOT HAVING A WALL HOUR BY
HOUR.
LOOK AT THIS NEW FOOTAGE FOR
BORDER PATROL SHOWING
HEAVILY ARMED MEN TAKING
MIGRANTS ACROSS OUR BORDER.
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN BEEN SAYING FOR MONTHS
YEARS ON THIS SHOW.
BORDER SECURITY FIRST, A
WALL FIRST.
MAKES PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
SAFER.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
THIS WE NEED TO ENSURE OF
THE SAFETY AND THE SECURITY
OF THE COUNTRY FIRST.
AND ALSO PROTECT THOSE
MIGRANTS WHO ARE BEING
EXPLOITED BY EVIL PEOPLE,
TRAFFICKED THROUGH CENTRAL
AMERICA AND MEXICO.
AND THE HORRIBLE CRIMES
COMMITTED OFTENTIMES ALONG
THE WAY.
WE HAVE TO HOLD FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANKFULLY WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT CONTINUING TO GET
THAT MESSAGE AND HE IS NOT
GIVING UP THE FIGHT.
HE TWEETED A RESPONSE ABOUT
A REPORT ABOUT MEXICAN
SOLDIERS PULLING GUNS ON OUR
NATIONAL GUARD, REALLY?
BETTER NOT HAPPEN AGAIN, THE
PRESIDENT SAID, WE ARE NOW
SENDING ARMED SOLDIERS TO
THE BORDER OF MEXICO.
IT'S NOT DOING NEARLY ENOUGH
IN APPREHENDING AND
RETURNING.
NOW, THE CRISIS IS REAL.
IT'S INTENSIFYING AND I
THINK IN LARGE PART BECAUSE,
WELL, IN CENTRAL AMERICA AND
MEXICO THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE